Alex Jones has just been ordered to pay
a lot of money
to the parents of victims of the Sandy
Hook shooting
because he went on the air and said that
the Sandy Hook shooting wasn't real that
it was a false flag it didn't really
happen and he he
spun a yarn you might say about what
what that shooting really was
Alex Jones because he got that story
wrong on the air it now has to pay
according to a court in Connecticut
more than 950 million dollars
to the families of eight victims of the
Sandy Hook shooting
that is in addition to a ruling from a
separate jury in Texas ordering Jones to
pay 4.1 million dollars in compensatory
damages and 45.2 million dollars in
punitive damages so we are now talking
about roughly
one billion dollars that Alex Jones a
radio host known for his Hyperbole and
kind of eccentric bizarre really out
there kind of implausible take sometimes
a man who rips off his shirt screaming
about the freaking frogs going gay that
guy because he got a story wrong on the
air has to pay a billion dollars
that's a lot of money for getting
something wrong on the radio don't you
think
but Michael he got it really wrong yeah
okay but Michael it was awful what he
said sure Michael it was really really
awful yeah okay fine I'm not I'm not
arguing I'm not I'm not disputing that
billion dollars for getting something
wrong in the radio
has has there ever been a radio host
ever who has not gotten something wrong
on the radio
even uh well probably me I'm not sure
that I've ever gotten a single thing no
maybe maybe even I have gotten some
things wrong but Michael it wasn't okay
yeah let's say that Alex Jones said he
got it as wrong as terrible it was the
worst reporting of any story ever in the
whole history of the world billion
dollars for getting that wrong
as far as I know Alex Jones hasn't
killed anybody
his
storytelling on the radio
didn't get anybody killed either
what kind of damages
are we going to see paid out by the
people who who lied about the covet
vaccines and who got the covid vaccines
wrong and who said that not only would
they protect you from getting the virus
and and transmitting the virus but that
they would actually they were totally
safe totally effective and now a bunch
of kids are dead because of heart
problems that even the CDC now admits
the vaccines cause very serious heart
problems and the ones that don't cause
heart problems cause blood clots
do those people have to pay any damages
because that wasn't just some Texas
radio host who got that story wrong that
was the entire establishment media and
all of our elected officials certainly
on the Democrat side
and the president of the United States
said these are totally fine these are
totally safe but I'm actually going to
mandate that you get these get these
shots even though kids are at very very
low risk from the virus and oh yeah okay
if you get heart problems and you die
oopsie Daisy I'm gonna deny that at
first and then I'm going to admit that
that happened but say it's not a big
deal
are they gonna have what what are they
gonna pay I don't think they're going to
pay a billion dollars or a million
dollars or one dollar I don't think
they're going to pay Jack diddly squat
and so I don't call call me kallus but I
just
I just think that paying a billion
dollars out
for getting something wrong on the radio
when you're a right winger even an
eccentric right-winger
seems a little bit crazy when the left
that lies about everything that lies in
a much more persuasive and serious way
about much more
urgent matters for the vast majority of
people they don't ever pay a price at
all
see that seems wrong to me that seems
kind of backwards to me
I think they ought to pay I think the
billion dollars that Alex Jones is
supposed to pay I think we need at least
a 100 a 1 000 a 100 000 times that
payout from the libs who lie constantly
in much more consequential wise and uh
now we've got some data here that
actually show the consequences of a
years-long campaign to trans the kids
you've got a 582 percent increase
in quote gender non-conforming kids in
one of the largest counties in one of
the most important states in the country
Montgomery County Schools
this is the largest county in Maryland
Maryland
is obviously right there by the Beltway
you know right there at the very heart
of our nation's capital
Montgomery County schools are reporting
a 582 increase in gender non-conforming
students in two years pretty wild you
can see this report here from The Daily
Caller
they've gathered this data this is a
near seven-fold increase from 2019 to
2022.
what are the odds
what are the odds how do you explain
that
well could be
it could be that there's something in
the water
I guess could be it could be that this
is a social contagion that is spreading
which is obviously what it is either way
though this really blows up the
Democrats narrative because the
Democrats on the in the libs broadly on
the sexual Revolution have for years
said look people are born this way
sexual orientation is immutable it's
from birth who would choose this you
can't have any conversion therapy social
forces have no effect on your sexual
orientation
well if that's the case then how is this
increasing so much
if you're just then it has to be
biological there's got to be some kind
of chromosomal issue right there's got
to be something in the womb
except that babies aren't babies in the
womb so that kind of that kind of messes
up their narrative there as well so it
messes up their abortion narrative it
messes up their gay rights narrative now
it's messing up the transgender
narrative 582 percent increase why is
that do you think it might have
something to do with the fact that
educators are teaching little kids all
the way down to kindergarten that boys
can be girls and girls could be boys no
that's crazy that's a crazy conspiracy
theory that's not happening and it is
happening and it's good by the way and
but it's not transiting the kids it's
not causing anyone to question their sex
or gender or change it except it is it's
a 582 increase except that's a crazy
conspiracy theory except it's happening
and it's true are you dizzy yet I can't
it's very hard to track
any of that
Democrats success
in trancing the kids Democrats success
in their political agenda has undermined
a lot of their narratives their
narratives unborn this way their
narratives on uh sex and gender are
totally different sex and gender are the
same
homosexual rights is that they're boys
and they're girls and some boys like
boys and some girls like girls but then
their narrative on transgenderism is
that actually there's no such thing as
girls and boys and boys can be girls and
girls can be boys none of the narratives
make sense okay
it's just power and and I guess this
this takes me back to Alex Jones it
takes me back to the the New York Times
right Joe Biden lies that's so cute and
great and wonderful Donald Trump lies
it's going to completely destroy the
Republic
the the arguments don't matter the
narratives don't matter the the
arguments don't matter the facts really
don't matter to them it's all framing
it's all narrative and it's why I I
can't you know stand up on the rooftops
and condemn Alex Jones or any of the
other uh celebrities
that the left turns on because they in
any way question the right wing
narrative I haven't I haven't talked
about Kanye's tweet you know Kanye sends
some fairly eccentric tweets every now
and again and I haven't made a big deal
about it even though the left is
insisting you have to disavow Khan yeah
you always have to disavow Kanye what
Kanye said
and and what Kanye is being accused of
is absolutely nothing compared to the
things that ilhan Omar has said that
Louis Farrakhan has said that Barack
Obama's former Pastor said and Barack
Obama's former pastor with connections
to all that that same kind of movement
and connections to Farrakhan and all the
rest of it and that all gets completely
written off Obama actually smiles next
to Louis Farrakhan and and celebrities
from Hollywood take pictures next to
Louis Farrakhan and Al Sharpton that's
all completely fine then Kanye West says
something that is one one thousandth as
harsh and severe and bigoted as any of
those people and we're told we have to
disavow this guy like it has absolutely
nothing to do with Kanye West's comments
it has everything to do with the fact
that Kanye West now is more right-wing
in many of his views he's pro-life he's
pro-family he's pro-public Christianity
and so that's why they go after him it
has nothing to do with the facts that
they're pretending to go after him for
they're going after Alex Jones not
because he got the Sandy Hook story
wrong that has nothing to do with it
they're going after Alex Jones because
they hate Alex Jones because Alex Jones
is right wing and he is popular and so
they're they've been de-platforming that
guy censoring that guy for years and
they found this one issue which is a
really good issue to go after him for
and they're making him pay a billion
dollars for getting a story wrong on the
air that's what it's about and that's
why I can't it's not I have no desire to
defend any of these comments or any of
these reports or stories or anything in
the abstract it's just that the game is
so obviously rigged read the New York
time headlines it's so disingenuous it's
in such bad faith that I see absolutely
no obligation
to entertain it and actually I think
it's probably wrong to entertain their
game and play their game because it
further ensconces them in power and it's
not in any way in good faith
and because they're trancing the kids
and that's bad it's really weird and bad
to trans the kids
I will be discussing Kanye on the member
block with my friend Spencer claven the
rest of the show is continuing now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]